هلع في اسرائيل لم تعشه وحدها منطقه تل
ابيب الكبرى فتلك قبلها حال المستوطنات
المحاذيه لقطاع غزه وعاشت الاجواء ذاتها
بلغت الرساله
[موسيقى]
تجاهد هنا وزيره المواصلات الاسرائيليه
ميرير الاصطناع الثبات وهي تفر نحو ملجا
على عجل
في محاوله لامتصاص بعض الذعر يتحدث اعلام
الاحتلال عن اعتراض القبه الحديديه عشرات
الصواريخ الفلسطينيه
جاء اذا اول ردود المقاومه على عمليه
القطاع والغارات المستمره هناك منذ فجر
الثلاثاء انه واحد من خيارات الرد
المفتوحه ضمن عمليه سمتها الغرفه المشتركه
لفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه فاروا الاحرار
تتمثل العمليه في توجيه مئات الصواريخ نحو
مواقع واهداف العدو ابتداء مما يسمى غلاف
غزه حتى تملا ابيب وفق بيان للغرفه
لا تكشف المقاومه الفلسطينيه عن جميع
اوراقها في مواجهه تصعيد الاحتلال المستمر
في القطاع قصفه المدفعي المتجدد وسلسله
غارات تشنها مقاتلاته منذ الصباح اوقعت
عشرات الشهداء الفلسطينيين بينهم طفله
ومثلهم من الجرحى في مناطق متفرقه من غزه
من زاويه رؤيته يتحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
ضرب منصات اطلاق صواريخ وقذائف تابعه
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي في انحاء القطاع
ويقول انه استهدف هناك ايضا خليه للجهاد
الاسلامي كانت تستعد لتنفيذ قصف صاروخي لا
تؤكد المقاومه ايا من تلك الانباء لكن
حكومه الاحتلال تباهي بانها حققت تفوقا
على المقاومه وفي غمره حديث عن اتصالات
مكثفه لوسطاء لمنع تصاعد الموقف الى
مواجهه مفتوحه يذهب بنيامين تنياهو في
اتجاه المعاكس
هذه تعليماتي نحن مستعدون لامكانيه توسيع
المعركه وتوجيه ضربات قاسيه جدا لغزه كما
نفعل الان وايضا لاحقا واضح لكم اننا
نتفوق عليهم انتم موجودون على الخط
الحدودي نقدر دعمكم لنا وصمودكم